oh i'm so excited today because we get
to watch
big a he's back
and he's actually dating again you think
after having the most catastrophic
relationship ever
ever displayed online it might well you
might want to cool down a bit but no
it says no get back on that horse i
can't wait to watch
what he's doing but when are you gonna
ask her i don't know
will you ask her for me ed please
okay ed i know bro is that his that is
his daughter right
can you imagine hey can you please ask
for me the woman i want to go with hey
excuse me my dad really wants to date
you
please say yes thank you i gotta be a
man okay yeah
okay how do you want to be asked now how
would you want to be asked out
tell me i'm amazing words of affirmation
exactly okay hey liz i think you're
amazing
and i want to take you out on a date
because i want to get to know you better
yes
so why basically we know what your steam
is
best mr big head so that opens the
bridge for more
okay liz you're amazing i want to take
you out on a date so i can get to know
you
better hey is liz around yeah
dude i'm amazed that they are even back
on the show i mean of course
money but it was such a disaster i can't
get past it
you're amazing oh you're so sweet and
you deserve somebody
you know that right yes stay with me yes
nice yeah yes i'm amazing i'm amazing
because yes yes i'm gonna met yeah
yes of course we all deserve slud how's
your dinner
we haven't eaten yet no oh yeah which
that's i actually called you over to
complain
i'm just kidding no we had to wind the
bread to bring in our lunch okay so
oh can you sit out i don't know if i'm
allowed to say it okay stand
okay anyways
okay dude this makes me feel like i'm
not socially awkward at all
this is great
all right it looks like he's about to
cry okay so
i think you're amazing okay he did it
first part uh i wanna ask out on a date
okay second part
and to get to know you
so we can get to know him and [ __ ] so we
can get used to each other
[Laughter]
um oh
oh bros i got a little hint for you if a
girl ever
responds with um with a voice crack
it's usually an indicator that she
doesn't really want to
but this however is tv baby there's
cameras on her
of course she has to say yes
come on come on come on
be good begin is back all right big ed
shaves his body before second please
don't show that
[Music]
oh my god he has a [ __ ] paint roller
for his mayo
what a he's upgraded what
are we just gonna brush past that
[Laughter]
what on god's earth so for those who
don't know he uses mayo in his hair
which apparently a lot of people swear
by but this is a new to me
the paint world where's your ball
oh what oh it's not mayo it's a shame
it's just
is that a paintbrush that's a paintbrush
i'm debating if i want to watch more or
not just shaving my
chest with mayonnaise and a paintbrush
what's the problem mother come in
after our first very emotional he's
trying to mask the hair by painting it
white
so it blends with his skin it's a smart
move a lot of people do it
liz called me the next day and told me
that she wants to go out on another date
i'm happy i'm elated what and i'm alive
we missed the first date
most people don't get a second chance
well i got a second date
i want to look good for liz but when it
comes to
my manscaping i'm a little bit out there
i don't like a hairy back or a hairy
chest
and something spicy it's god oh shoot
mom can you come here
no oh duh
stop do not make your mama shave your
shirt
no no no you go salon you got salon and
doom don't make your mama
put mama pop by my mind ponytail
taking the hair off my chest and my back
what for
because it's gross you're a man i don't
know why you're
taking off your hair you're going to
look like she wants to look younger
okay fine but okay that's a natural
thing for a man to have
hair right if you don't have hair i'm
sure a lot of men would like to have
hair what a character
okay liz will be seeing a lot more of me
on this date and i don't want her to see
a hairy little animal
oh what the [ __ ] am i looking at dude so
he's expecting you know a little bit of
bing bong
on second date i mean all right go for
it i don't know
just don't put this stuff around your
private area i guarantee you
you're gonna suffer too late here how
many let me have it
too late too late
okay they didn't show so it seems to be
a little bit of um
i'm missing some pieces but this is all
that's up on youtube so
this is their first case wow
hey so what do you think it's cute
it's cute so um
hopefully i get to sleep here because
there's a sofa
oh good save it bliss are you okay blink
five times
blink one time just breathe so we know
great surprise for you
oh yes look at that
that looks fancy
he popped the cherry wow we're not so
different you and i had our food
champagne again black shirt why don't
you do a toast and i do a toast
oh my god they don't know how to hold a
champagne glass
why does this bother me so much i'll go
first your sense of humor
okay what happened to her eye you're
here i
am here so i did it you did do it i did
it right
did what no i'm just so nervous around
you
it just took me a while to get used to
your your beautiful face
but um it took me a while to get used to
you
[Laughter]
anyways um thank you pat um
you gotta work your way up right the
base thing that we don't have in europe
but
everyone talks about in movies right you
got to get the bases
you can't just jump a rooney straight
into kissa rooney
come on big ed you're breaking lots of
relations
yes can i kiss you oh he's an asker
don't make it weird yeah i won't
don't make it weird here we go
it's gonna be weird i guarantee you
sorry okay
how this sounds
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is this oh
no stop stop
stop that wow stop it this is what it's
like kissing big
that was the second sketch i've ever had
so that's out of the way now i can relax
now it can be normal no it will be
normal i guess
there's hope for anyone sweet dreams
one more kiss
too soon for that
my skin i need to get out of it
i like how she's normal too like no dude
no too soon for that
[Music]
nice good save good save just
just kidding yeah it was a little joke i
made
[ __ ] well that i didn't expect it to be
this painful my god
okay this is after their night hey
pumpkin peach peaches peaches peaches
he tasted like a peach last night cheers
oh oh
no oh god he's so
weird what
you tasted like a peach last night bruh
you tasted like pizza i'm calling out
color cops
call the cops screams into the app
why would he say that oh my god
you know i have so much anxiety of
dumb i've said by accident that sounds
dumb
even though you don't mean it right i
never said actually
i feel great watching this last night
was
off the charts oh my god the look of
this man
so man i got laid look at him
[Laughter]
we um
he wants to say it so badly he wants to
say it
liz is like you okay fine but don't just
don't keep it off the cameras all right
did you guys have sex okay so
a real gentleman never kiss and tell
it's the right answer here beget you
understand that right
we all know you already did it you don't
have to say it
don't be that guy big a yeah i mean we
of course yeah of course i
i put my pee pee in her can i tell you
more
we made love all night all night
it was incredible like incredible i
don't need to know that you don't have
to tell us
you can keep some stuff cameras
that is wild i don't think anyone would
have a problem
it will go down in big head history as
no i'm all right all right that's enough
how long does a yap about this
i can't listen to it is he a good kisser
i had to teach him how to kiss yeah we
saw that
[Music]
he's a big kiss i know i made the joke
but it was funny
give me give me okay
like i have to train him to do a lot of
things but
we laughed about it hey we didn't really
get that sort of
uh you know from a big edge or a side of
the story
he has a child he has had sex before
just so we're clear
okay
[Applause]
why would you do that why would you push
her into the ocean
body slam dude she looks like neapolitan
ice cream man
it's hot that ocean looks disgusting
and what is this the brighton beach ill
ah
you know no relationship is perfect
but i want to be here forever
and wants to be a list forever place
your bets will the relationship work out
oh wait i'm sorry they broke up
is the reason that you two are no longer
a couple because you were taking the
relationship too fast
um
yes sorry um
yes yes we moved way too fast
like she didn't have a chance our
relationship didn't have a chance
oh no what was so sad
like that's the problem okay sure i got
hurt
you hurt me just
completely left me and you promised me
you wouldn't leave me
this month has been hell damn
did you do it it's like history repeats
itself
what the hell why do you keep doing this
you blocked me and went to vegas
and ranted about your sugar babies no
what big yeah you did not rent even cola
looks
shocked what so confused right now are
you saying that
ed was hanging out with other women
no i didn't expect to be dumped and then
him be out in vegas
living the life oh
nice after you guys broke up
did you know he was hanging out in vegas
how soon like two days
oh oh [ __ ] two days
damn goddamn bro
that's cold three days dad hey
you horny bastard you couldn't wait
three days of a [ __ ]
well well well where where
where well nothing in this video was
surprising except the fact that liz
actually decided to hook up with him but
hey
to each his own everyone thought she was
a paid actress
she actually liked him yeah it seemed
like uh she was kind of planted there
for a while didn't they okay here here's
my little say you know how everyone is
like oh there's one for
there's a person for everyone not no
no no i think most people aren't ready
for a relationship because they have
their own
issues to deal with and when you're in a
relationship those issues will come to
life
onto the other person and maybe that
person is very capable to help you get
through those
okay it can happen but a lot of time it
just becomes this really
toxic horrible nasty situation
where people's lives get wasted or
ruined
and uh i don't think it's fair that's
just what i think
what do you think epic subscribe and
epic like video
and epic tomorrow see you bro fist
[Music]
epic
like a puppy
poop pads catch a melon gobble butt even
ones that i can't see
just download it for free for free [ __ ]
download
it oh yeah
i'm gonna go with it i got something for
[Music]
you